we are asked what is the constant of
proportionality in the equation 4y is
equal to 8x pause this video and have a
go at this question
all right so we might be used to seeing
constants of proportionality when we
have equations in a slightly different
form a constant of proportionality is
what do you multiply x by to get to y so
y would be equal to
our constant of proportionality times x
times x
but this isn't written in this that form
so what we do is manipulate it a little
bit so that we can see it in that form
and the obvious thing is we just need to
solve for y so right now it says 4y is
equal to 8x well if we want to solve for
y we can just divide both sides by 4 and
we are left with
y is equal to 8 divided by 4 which is 2
times x
well now the constant of proportionality
jumps out at us
to get y we have to multiply x by 2.
that is our constant of proportionality
let's do another example
here we're asked which equation has a
constant of proportionality equal to
one-half
again
pause the video try to answer it
yourself
okay so what we i'm just going to go
equation by equation and calculate their
constant or for their constants of
proportionality and see which one has
a constant of proportionality equal to
one-half
so this one right over here choice a
clearly has a constant of
proportionality of 1 8 so we can just
rule that out
equation b right over here clearly has a
constant of proportionality of 4 not 1
half so we could rule that one out let's
see the constant of proportionality for
equation c
if we want to solve for y we could
divide both sides by 6. and so we're
going to get
y
is equal to 3 6 times x well 3 6 is the
same thing as one-half times x and so
there you have it we have a constant of
proportionality of one-half that's the
choice i like and we can verify that
this one doesn't work if you divide if
you want to solve for y you divide both
sides by 3
and you get y is equal to 9 divided by 3
is 3 x so here our constant of
proportionality is 3 so we can feel good
about choice c